[Music]
hey what is up everybody its Anna Mack
here for anime uproar and in this video
we will be talking about Eskin ors sun
praising enemy scorching demon frying
power by which I mean his mysterious and
overpowered ability called sunshine even
though at this point in the story we
know a lot more about sunshine than we
did before including how it works and
what its divine origins are there is
still a lot that we don't know about
this ability including the question of
how and why s Canora came to possess it
in the first place how did this
particular human at this particular
point in history come to possess one of
the most powerful abilities in the
entire series in this video I will be
telling you everything we know so far
about Eska Norse epic power and then I
will go a step further I will tell you
how I believe as Canora came to possess
this power in the first place why he was
chosen out of all the other possible
vessels and I will tell you why I
believe that Eskin or getting sunshine
is all part of a larger plan concocted
3,000 years ago by none other than
Merlin and the original goal thir but
before we jump into the epicness
I want to thank echo of soul for
generously sponsoring this video echo of
soul is an MMORPG that is clearly
inspired by fantasy anime and as an
anime fan I obviously love the idea of
being able to choose from seven unique
classes and play as an epic anime hero
or a badass anime why food whatever
floats your boat
the first thing I noticed as soon as I
started playing the game was the quality
of the graphics and the absolutely
beautiful soundtrack like seriously
sometimes I just keep the game loaded
while doing other things because the
music is so epic and it pumps me up the
game has over 2000 stories that you can
complete as quests and this allows you
to grow your characters skill while
having a great time along the way you
can level up quickly without unnecessary
hassle and you can unlock dungeons raids
and player-versus-player battles at
level 10 which is really fun you can
equip a wide variety of really cool
items based on your character's class
and skill and you can change your
character's look by equipping different
outfits I also love how you can mount
different interesting beasts and just
ride around on them like
boss running and jumping and all sorts
of fun stuff
thank you echo sole very cool try it out
for yourself it's a lot of fun just
click the link in the description and
now on to s kannur but quick warning
this video will contain manga spoilers
that are related to s kannur and his
ability i simply cannot do justice to
the subject without getting into the
manga material so please proceed with
caution you have been warned alright so
we know that s Kannur is a 40 year old
human and that at night he is by far the
weakest of the seven deadly sins
in fact the single lowest power level or
combat class ever recorded in the seven
deadly sins was the combat class of
nighttime s kannur which is only 15 but
what sets s kannur apart from every
other human and what makes him one of
the strongest characters in the cemetery
sins is his special ability called
sunshine because he possesses sunshine
as the sun rises each morning asking
horsepower groves immensely every hour
until it reaches its maximum height at
noon as his power grows so does his body
and s Kannur goals from being thin and
frail to incredibly tall and muscular
along with his physical appearance s
Connors personality also changes as noon
approaches he goes from being a meek and
nervous person to an incredibly arrogant
grandiose and prideful machine of
destruction which explains why s Kannur
is the sin of pride now because s Kannur
gets his power from the Sun he is also
known as the master of the Sun so wait
does that mean that while we're over
here saying praise the Sun the Sun is
out there praising its master s kannur
hmm anyway at noon s Connors power is at
its highest for one minute and at this
time s kannur is able to enter a state
known as the one according to Merlin
when this happens s Kannur is the
strongest of all the seven deadly sins
as he becomes an invincible incarnation
of power now to be fair Merlin said this
before the most recent power-ups that
King and Bond received and also before
meliodas begins absorbing the
commandments but still clearly the
change that s Kannur experiences between
nighttime and daytime is unbelievable
the name of s Kannur sacred treasure is
the divine axe
Rheda a massive and insanely heavy
battle-ax in his day time for meskan or
gives off a great amount of heat which
can actually hurt the people who are in
his vicinity but his sacred treasure
allows him to gather all of that excess
energy inside the axe and then release
it when he needs it we eventually
learned that the ability sunshine is
actually a blessing or grace created by
the supreme deity the ruler of the
goddess gland and it was originally
bestowed upon my L the strongest of the
four Archangels Maya was believed to
have been killed by aster Rosa 3,000
years ago and after miles death sunshine
somehow passed on to s kannur although
we don't know how exactly this happened
or why s kannur was chosen to inherit
the power nearly three thousand years
after its original user lost it later on
in the video I will give you my theory
about how and why s kannur inherited
sunshine in the first place and how all
of this fits into a three
thousand-year-old plan concocted by the
original Golder and Merlin that part of
the video will also contain some major
spoilers about miles so I am now warning
you for the second time just so you
don't say I did it
but first let's discuss everything else
we know about Eskin or himself because
of the wild fluctuations in strength
between day and night it is virtually
impossible to measure the true extent of
Eskin or power especially when he is in
the state known as the one his power
level has been measured at well over
100,000 but judging from his feats and
his ability to effectively challenge
meliodas esta rosa and zell drous it is
clear that at the peak of his power
ESCA noir is way stronger than 100,000
however the big question is how did s
Kannur a mere human become so powerful
in the first place ESCA noir was born as
a prince of a britannia kingdom called
Castelli oh he had an older brother who
would often mistreat him but then one
day s canora's unique power called
sunshine suddenly awoke inside of him
and he broke his brothers arm by
accident basically while defending
himself after this incident and because
of the appearance of his mysterious
power the people of the castello kingdom
began to look at s Kannur as a monster
his own parents disowned him and after
the kingdom soldiers tried to kill him
for being a
danger to the kingdom he was barely able
to escape with his life by hiding in a
barrel and drifting off to sea it is
important to mention that s Connors life
was actually saved by a mysterious woman
called Rosa we know almost nothing about
her other than the fact that she saved s
Kannur by helping him to hide inside the
barrel which he used to drift off the
sea and we also know that she calls
herself his ally and she sheds tears as
she tells him goodbye which indicates
that she seems to have some type of
strong emotional connection to s Kannur
but beyond that she appears to be a
normal human when we eventually learned
that Maya lost his divine grace called
sunshine not because he was killed but
because he became one of the 10
commandments this major revelation still
didn't answer a very important question
why did s kannur in particular inherit
sunshine
even though s Canora is a mere human who
was born nearly 3,000 years after mile
became a commandment he's obviously not
a reincarnation of mile like elizabeth
is the reincarnation of the goddess
Elizabeth because mile never actually
died so why s kannur and where was
sunshine for 3,000 years during the
period of time between the end of the
previous holy war and Eska Norse birth
was sunshine passing on two different
humans from generation to generation for
nearly three millennia until it
eventually passed on to s Kannur I mean
maybe but we haven't heard about anyone
else possessing this mysterious power in
the past and nearly everyone who
encounters a second or including beings
who have been alive since the previous
holy wars seemed genuinely surprised
that anyone other than my ELF possesses
sunshine
so was sunshine just like floating
around in the air for 30 centuries until
it decided to fly into esken or his body
or did someone keep sunshine hidden away
until they found the perfect vessel at
the perfect time and that vessel was s
Kannur if we go with this last
assumption it would mean that the fact
that s Canora came to possess sunshine
was not an accident
instead s Kannur was deliberately chosen
to gain possession of sunshine as part
of some greater plan
and this is the perfect time for me to
reveal to all of you my theory for how
and why s Connor came to possess
sunshine if we think back to the
mysterious woman known as Rosa who saved
esken ORS life when he was younger we
could assume that she is just some
random human who knew s Kannur and felt
bad for him and decided to help him for
some reason although the fact that she
was in tears would have to mean that she
had some close connection to him but
strangely s Kannur himself never gives
us any clue as to why Rosa cared about
him so much
but what if Rosa wasn't a normal human
at all
what if Rosa's true identity is not
other than Merlin why do I think that
Rosa could very likely be Merlin because
this would finally explain how and why s
kannur came into possession of sunshine
in the manga we learned that the
previous holy war ended because the
original goal third the creator of the
doll Gotha
altered the memories of my L and
everyone who knew him in order to make
them think that he was actually a member
of the ten commandments this act forced
the goddess clan to seal the demons in
the coffin of eternal darkness because
they weren't strong enough to kill them
outright and in the process the
goddesses lost possession of their own
physical bodies as well and so the holy
war ended in a sort of stalemate with
neither side conclusively defeated we
also know that Merlin knew the original
goal thir well in fact he was her master
and she studied magic under his guidance
the original goal Thurs greatest wish
and mission in life was to stop the
endless cycle of war between the
different races and clans and even
though he sacrificed his life to stop
the holy war for the time being he knew
that this was not a decisive end and
that the war would continue after the
coffin of eternal darkness was opened
once again some demons had escaped the
coffin of eternal darkness before it was
even opened including fraud Ren and the
red demon who destroyed the fairy Kings
forest so a brilliant wizard like Golder
would definitely have known that the
piece he created was only a temporary
solution
I believe that Oh G go thir entrusted
his greatest student Merlin to continue
his mission when the
I came just like he entrusted the doll
goal third to do the same we must
remember that Merlin along with meliodas
was the one who formed the seven deadly
sins in the first place
it was Merlin who first found s Kannur
and recruited him into the seven deadly
sins when he mater s kannur instantly
fell in love with Merlin because she was
the only person who was not afraid of
him but actually impressed by his unique
power we must also remember that after
the destruction of Danna for Merlin had
sealed away a large chunk of melioidosis
power until he learned to control his
anger this shows that Merlin is clearly
capable of sealing away a massive amount
of power and keeping it sealed until the
right moment so what if after my lbk
master OSA his grace sunshine did not
simply randomly leave his body and
wander around in the wind until it
bumped into s kannur what if Merlin
sealed sunshine away for three thousand
years waiting for the right moment and
the right person to give the ability to
King Bartra Leonys had the power of
vision for his entire life ever since he
was a boy so it is possible that he saw
Eskin or or a glimpse of Eskin or in a
vision back when s Kannur was still a
child at that point merlin could have
heard about the vision and transformed
into rosa in order to see what s Kannur
was like and whether he was truly worthy
of inheriting sunshine when she decided
that he was worthy she unsealed the
power and gave it to s Kannur then
because she needed s Kannur to survive
in order to fulfill his destiny and
become one of the seven deadly sins she
made sure to save his life by helping
him escape his own kingdom we already
know that even Vivian Merlin's
apprentice was able to effectively
transform into Gil Frost and fool almost
everyone
so surely Merlin would have no problem
changing her appearance and turning into
Rosa in fact you could definitely argue
that Rosa and Merlin already look quite
similar in fact they look so similar
that when s Kannur first sees Merlin he
actually calls her Rosa and then she
corrects him saying I am the magician
Merlin but if Merlin is Rosa and
everything was going according to her
plan then why was Rosa crying as she was
saying goodbye to s Kannur I think she
was crying because she knew that the
power she gave him sunshine was a very
difficult burden s can or could never be
a normal human again for the rest of his
life he would have to deal with everyone
being afraid of him and thinking that he
is some kind of monster for the rest of
his life he would have to deal with
having two very different and opposing
personalities and finally he would have
to deal with controlling this immense
power we have seen that Merlin cares
deeply for Arthur another human that she
believed was destined to play a major
role in her and og go thurs masterplan
Merlin was grooming Arthur for something
great and she becomes extremely upset
and emotional when Arthur is seemingly
killed by kusa so when we take that into
consideration the fact that she was
grooming Arthur for so long I don't
think it is a big leap to assume that
Merlin gave Eskin or the power of
sunshine because she knew that he would
need it in order to fight against the
ten commandments and all of their other
opponents in the years to come however
she still cried when saying goodbye to
the young s Kannur because she knew that
by choosing him she was also condemning
him to a very difficult life but with
that said all of this still leaves two
more unanswered questions first off why
would Merlin choose to give s Cunard the
power when he was still a child instead
of waiting for him to become a fully
formed adult I believe that the answer
to this lies in the fact that sunshine
is a very difficult power to master and
Eska nor would need many years to master
it before the Ten Commandments were
released
so Merlin had to give him the power at a
young age the second question is if
Merlin was indeed Rosa and she knew s
can orb back when he was still a child
why didn't she simply tell him who she
really was from the start why would she
bother transforming into some human
named Rosa after all when she mentors
Arthur she does it as herself as Merlin
she doesn't disguise herself as someone
else well I believe that she disguised
herself as Rho sub because she didn't
want s Kannur to recognize her when he
eventually became one of the seven
deadly sins she didn't want him to blame
her for cursing him with the power of
sunshine and she didn't want him to
think that he was just some pawn in a
master plan can [ __ ]
by her and og go third thousands of
years ago
if Eskin or knew that he could have
lived a normal life if only Merlin
hadn't specifically chosen him to
inherit sunshine he might have felt
betrayed and his massive pride may have
led him to refuse to join the seven
deadly sins but this way when he finally
meets Merlin in her normal form he feels
an instant attraction to her and because
she treats him kindly unlike everyone
else because everyone else is afraid of
him
ESCA noir agrees to join the seven
deadly sins without a problem
and so to sum things up i believe that
the reason why ESCA noir in particular
received the ability known as sunshine
at the time that he did was because he
was specifically chosen by Merlin and I
believe that before the power passed on
to us kannur Merlin had sealed it away
just as she later seals away melioidosis
power only to release it again when the
moment is right I believe that
ESCA noir is going to play a major part
in the master plan concocted 3,000 years
ago by Merlin and og gol thir to finally
end the holy war once and for all as I
mentioned in my video talking about the
dalgo thir this master plan may be to
separate the different realms including
the human realm from each other so that
they can no longer keep fighting this is
hinted at in the intro to the anime when
we hear that the story of the seven
deadly sins takes place in ancient times
when the human and non-human worlds had
not yet split which seems to imply that
at some point in the future the human
and non-human worlds will somehow be
separated but let me know what you guys
think do you agree with my theory that s
Canora came to possess sunshine because
the power was given to him by Merlin and
do you think that Merlin knew s Canora
back when he was still a child because
she was living in the skies as Rosa
finally do you agree with me that Merlin
is trying to carry out a master plan
concocted by her former master original
goal through 3,000 years ago a plan that
will one day bring an end to the holy
wars once and for all let me know down
below I'd love to hear from you if you
enjoyed this video and want to see more
content along these lines you can leave
a like to let me know and if you are new
to the channels don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
and if you'd like to support more
content like this in the future you can
check out our online
store where we have original anime
inspired merch like this praise the Sun
shirt created by pro artist guzelman ik
and lastly we are organizing a create
your own original seven deadly sins
character contest you can submit your
original ideas by following us on
twitter and instagram at anime uproar
and replying to the relevant thread i
will link the relevant thread in the
description so just click there and
submit your ideas please read the thread
for all the rules and instructions
before submitting the winning character
will be brought to life by once again
Pro manga artist coos Oh Mari and coos
Oh Mari already did an amazing job not
only bringing to life our exclusive
shirt designs but also the winners of
our previous two contests which were for
boku no hero and attack on titan feel
free to check out coos omaree's work and
show him some love I will link him in
the description as well as always thank
you all so much for watching and until
next time see our space cowboys
[Music]
you